Alright folks, welcome back to the continuing ICT 2022 free mentorship on YouTube.
And I'm taking you into the e-mini S&P futures contract for June 2022, and I saw questions
in previous videos where they're asking about June and we're in the month of May.
These contracts are delivered by contract month, so we're about to a couple weeks end
trading of June contract, then we'll roll over into September 2022 contract, but we
have a couple weeks still trading June.
Toss that in there for an extra charge.
Alright, so hourly chart.
Obviously we are looking at a swing low here to swing high, getting our range, here's equilibrium,
so the market did in fact drop down into a discount and a fair break up.
So we have a market that is in what?
An oversold condition.
Do we need an indicator to plot that or determine that?
Nope, absolutely not.
The rectangle is there just to draw special attention for you, the viewer.
The fib is just to highlight exactly where equilibrium is, anything above that level
would be considered premium, anything below it, discount.
So we moved from this high down into a fair break up and below equilibrium, so we're in
a discount.
Alright, here's the five minute chart.
And notice that we had this run up in here, I mentioned in Twitter, and again my Twitter
feed is not a signal service, so that way we understand one another, but I was highlighting
the idea that this was likely to go higher and it needed to go for a premium relative
to this high and that low.
So we moved up into a premium, then we slid aggressively, taking out relative equal lows,
so below this low here, and here is what, sell-side liquidity.
It was quick to do that right at the opening at 9.30, short little bounce, then one more
time below the low here, taking out sell-side, for anyone that wanted to capture a long here,
they knocked them out.
Then we had a shift in market structure and then rolled up even higher, rebalancing all
of this, dropped back down into an area here where we have a five minute fair break up.
Trades down into it, I mentioned on Twitter that we would likely trade higher and take
out the short-term high here, and here, so I mentioned the morning high, that's this
here, that was going to be the draw on liquidity and we saw that run here, and actually it
went a little bit higher than I thought it would for the morning, ultimately up into
a fair break up here for a really, really deep premium from low to high, trade up into
that and then pull back inside the range between this low and the high.
So on a one minute chart, we're zoomed in here and you can see the morning I did a small
trade here, I recorded this, did a small little vignette, shared it on Twitter, took the parcels
here at the time of posting the tweet and then the limit order giving hit here.
Then the only other trade I had today was waiting for it to drop down to a discount
and when it did, I went long here, had a little bit of heat here, not much, it was like five
handles, so bearable, stop loss was just below the swing low over here.
So did it hit it?
Did it look like it was going to?
I don't know, I wasn't looking at the chart at the moment it happened, the trade here,
I don't care, but it ended up coming back up and I mentioned that we would run this
high right here because we've taken out the sell stops here after running higher.
So we had a shift in market structure back here earlier and then we basically consolidated
and dropped down to take out the sell stops.
So anyone that was lucky enough to go long here and wrote it up to here, the algorithm
drops back down, clears the board, taking out the sell stops below here, I'm buying
those sell stops, had a little bit of heat here, we rallied and I mentioned that we would
start going higher now because we've cleared out the sell stops.
And then going over into the one minute chart with a little bit more detail, here's the
initial drop.
Now here's what I want to bring to your attention, we had a short term little shift in market
structure here and I know some of you see this and you see this one here, which one
is the shift in market structure?
Well, I'm playing the run up here to a premium, like I was mentioning on my Twitter feed this
morning.
So if this is the range I'm working within, the shift in market structure occurs here
when it takes out that high, drops down to a fair value gap, which is what I bought.
I didn't believe we were going to take out the lows here because we should have done
it at 830 news, it didn't do it.
So this is a deep retracement and then sent it higher to go into a premium right before
930 AM and then they sank it down.
Notice there's no model entry here, that's telling, okay, it's tipping its hand to you.
Because there's no real setup and it's a rush to get down here, it's clearing out sell stop
liquidity, going down, rallying, suckering in longs, trying to pick the bottom, knocking
those individuals out.
Now they are not allowed to be long, their stop's taken.
Nobody in retail usually will take a reentry after something like that, they're afraid.
It rallies up, comes down to a fair value gap, shift in market structure here, rallies,
relative equal highs, drops back down in, fair value gap, order block, rallies once
more, goes into the imbalance here, consolidates, bumps up just above the short-term high here,
then drops one more time, clearing the liquidity out here.
And you see my entry was at 41.20 on five contracts.
And again, here is the tweet, okay, and I'll have the link posted in the description below
this video, so you can click and see it, it was time and date stamped, exactly as you
see it here.
All right, so it says, sell stop liquidity is taken, free to run to 41.43 and a half,
that's this level here, while it was here.
So continue on, first partial, which is when I tweeted, you can see that in the timeline
this morning, three contracts were sold at 41.39 and a quarter, and finally the final
two were filled on a limit order at 41.43 and three quarters.
And ultimately it rode a little bit higher, which was fine, I was juggling a lot of administrative
tasks this morning, but nonetheless, you can see all the trades are here and here.
So was it a lot now?
But hopefully you guys learned something today.
We have a non-farm payroll scenario this week, it's first week of the month, transitioning
from one month into another, and I typically like to have all my trading done by Wednesday,
and because I've done what I've shown here today, I'm satisfied with this particular
week.
Now, some of you are going to be like, this is crazy.
You have Wednesday still, you have Thursday still, you have Friday, you're welcome to
do that, but I have to be disciplined and being consistent.
How you get there is having rules, rules and engagement.
So you're welcome to practice, but I'm not trying to hunt anything more this week, because
frankly it can go either direction, it can go higher or lower, based on that daily chart.
So because I don't have a clear definitive objective, I'm going to sit on my hands and
just be content with what I've shown you all here today.
And that's going to be it for this week.
I'm going to be finishing up with my private group, I have a lot of things I have to fulfill
for them, and it means I'll be quiet on Twitter and I'll be quiet on YouTube until Thursday.
I'll put another video up on Thursday evening, and until then, be safe.